Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is the first paper in Two Minute Papers
that showcased so stunning results that people
called it out to be an April Fools' day joke.
It is based on a deep neural network, and
the concept is very simple: you choose an
artistic style, you make a terrible drawing,
and it creates a beautiful painting out of it.
If you would like to know more about deep
neural networks, we've had a ton of fun
with them in previous episodes, I've put a
link to them in the description box!
I expect an onslaught of magnificent results
with this technique to appear very soon.
It is important to note that one needs to
create a semantic map for each artistic style
so that the algorithm learns the correspondence
between the painting and the semantics. However,
these maps have to be created only once and
can be used forever, so I expect quite a few
of them to show up in the near future, which
greatly simplifies the workflow.
After that, these annotations can be changed
at will, you press a button, and the rest
is history.
Whoa! Wicked results.
Some of these neural art results are so good
that we should be creating a new class of
Turing tests for paintings. This means that
we are presented with two images, one of them
is painted by a human, and one by a computer.
We need to click the ones that we think were
painted by a human.
Damn, curses!
As always, these techniques are new and heavily
experimental, and this usually means that
they take quite a bit of time to compute.
The presentation video you have seen was sped
up considerably. If these works are worthy
of further attention, and I definitely think
they are, then we can expect great strides
towards interactivity in followup papers very
soon. I am really looking forward to it and
we Fellow Scholars will have a ton of fun
with these tools in the future.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!